I was asked to do this by the State
Department I didn't know mr. Yarmuth
from a hole in the wall the name of your
Mac was given to me by Kurt Vogel
ambassador I was asked to meet with him
I did meet with him i briefed them two
of them on everything I did and I have a
very nice text at the end explaining how
honest and straightforward I was which
is which I am you don't have any issue
with a foreign power investigating a
political rival if the president I do if
you didn't do anything but if he bribed
the president of that country I have an
issue if they don't investigate so the
ends justify the means no opposite way
around it'd be totally illegitimate not
to investigate it if a president if a
vice president the United States go
somewhere and extort the president of
that country or bribes the president of
that country to get his son out of
trouble I'd find it extraordinary if
they didn't investigate the Ukrainians
today say that when they investigated
this prosecutor Joe Biden's son wasn't
even working for the gas company
what are they lying in yes he yeah it
was what he began working for you just
read the New York Times he began working
for this company in 2015 he didn't stop
working through the company in two
months ago and the the investigation was
tanked meaning dropped in 2016 so that's
completely untrue right as a
non-government employee to investigate
them to freelance ultimately I wasn't
freelancing why why do you say things
like that I mean I there's no basis on
which you should say that I'm
freelancing the reality is that there is
an alternative theory of how this crime
was committed and the crime was
committed by Democrats and as his lawyer
it's my obligation to establish those
facts are you willing to testify in
front of Congress well there's a lot of
problems with that I mean would I like
to testify and tell my story sure I've
been telling it all the time in fact you
know my story nothing I can tell them
that you can't read online from the very
beginning I've been totally transparent
about this there are things that I can't
testify to because I'm a lawyer
this week uh he asked me how I'm doing
we talked about golf and anything we
talked about relating to the case I
can't tell you but presidents in a very
good mood and he's a good friend he's
been a friend for 30 years are you at
all concerned about your future because
you very no I'm not concerned about my
future what I did is perfectly lawful
perfectly legal I find it completely
extraordinary that you're spending all
this time asking me about what I did all
this time should be spent on the
pay-for-play scheme the Biden setup in
which he made millions and billions of
dollars using his son and having his son
sell his office that should shock you
but because we are distorted this
left-wing distortion that goes on you're
asking me about the process that I
followed to uncover one of the biggest
scandals I should be considered a
whistleblower
I should be getting whistleblower
protection I actually found facts that
are true the other guy half of what he
wrote is false